مرحباً، أهلاً بالجميع. كيف حالكم جميعاً اليوم؟ سيكون هذا درساً
رائعاً في الاستماع والتحدث. أنا سعيد جداً بحضوركم جميعاً. أهلاً
بالجميع. الأمر أشبه بتدريب العضلات. الدماغ ليس عضلة ولكننا نبني
روابط. نبني روابط أقوى، لذا هدفنا اليوم هو أن تحاولوا
أن تكون إجاباتكم طبيعية وسلسة وواضحة. قد تلاحظون أنني أكتب
بينما تتحدثون. حاولوا النظر إلى بعض هذه التصحيحات التي أقوم بها،
بعضها مجرد إعادة صياغة لما يمكنكم قوله بشكل أفضل قليلاً.
هذا سيحسن طلاقتكم. لكني لا أريد أن يقاطع ذلك حديثكم.
فقط حاولوا التركيز على أن تكونوا طبيعيين وسلسين وواضحين. الهدف كله هو
أن تَفهَموا وأن تُفهَموا. إليكم سؤال. ما هو الشيء الوحيد الذي تشعرون بالرضا
تجاهه بالفعل عند تحدثكم باللغة الإنجليزية؟ لا أعرف. هذا سؤال صعب. حسناً، أعتقد
الأمر كالتالي، الآن عندما أتحدث الإنجليزية، لا أشعر بالحرج إذا
صحح لي أحدهم شيئاً ما. لذا أعتقد أن هذا هو الشيء الذي أشعر بالرضا تجاهه الآن.
هذا يأتي مع الخبرة حقاً. هذا يساعد فعلاً. والسؤال التالي، ما هو
المجال الذي تعتقد أنه قد يكون صعباً في مقابلة باللغة الإنجليزية ولماذا؟ أعتقد
أنه سيكون مثل المفردات الجديدة و(أنا) يجب أن أعبر أو كما ذكرتَ حضرتك،
محاولة التعبير عمّا أفكر فيه بوضوح وإيجاز.
بإيجاز. نعم. حسناً. ومحاولة قول شيء بوضوح وإيجاز.
حسناً. أتفق معك. كل هذه الأشياء يمكن تحسينها أيضاً كلما مارستها أكثر. لذا يمكننا
أن نحاول تحسين طريقة قولنا للأشياء لنجعلها أكثر وضوحاً أو إيجازاً في
درس اليوم. أحد أشهر أسئلة المقابلات التي يطرحونها هو
"حدثني عن نفسك". يريدونك أن تنفتح. يريدونك أن تكسر الحاجز.
لقد طرحوا هذا السؤال مليون مرة. بعض الناس يستخدمون هذا من أجل
إبهار الشخص الآخر أو كما قلت، لكسر الحاجز. ماذا يريدون حقاً؟
ما يريدونه حقاً هو شيء موجز، أليس كذلك؟ من دقيقة إلى دقيقتين. ملخص
ذي صلة بخلفيتك المهنية، مهاراتك، أهدافك المهنية، هذه
الأشياء الأساسية التي يحتاجون لمعرفتها. لماذا؟ لأنه إذا كان هذا هو السؤال الأول،
فهم بحاجة إلى تكوين انطباع أول جيد جداً، قوي وإيجابي للغاية عنك
من خلال هذا السؤال الأول الذي يطرحونه. إليكم نشاط لوظيفة أحلامكم. ما هي
الإنجازات أو المهارات الرئيسية (من واحدة إلى اثنتين) التي ستسلطون الضوء عليها في إجابتكم على سؤال "حدثني عن
نفسك"؟ ما هما المهارتان أو الإنجازان اللذان ستسلط الضوء عليهما؟ أعتقد
أنه سيكون شيئاً متعلقاً باتخاذ القرارات. وأعتقد أن الآخر سيكون
بخصوص، لا أعرف كيف أقول ذلك، مثل عندما تتعلم شيئاً بنفسك.
إذاً مهارة واحدة هي أنك جيد في اتخاذ القرارات وأنك...
والأخرى هي أنك تعرف الكثير عن نفسك. الأخرى هي مثلاً إذا
كنت لا أعرف شيئاً، أبحث عنه حتى أعرفه. حسناً. وأنا
أحاول أن أتعلم بنفسي قبل أن... بنفسي. نعم، أي أتعلم بنفسي قبل أن أطلب المساعدة.
أتعلم بنفسي. إذاً أنت تعتبر نفسك شخصاً مستقلاً.
قادراً على العمل بمفردك بشكل مستقل. هل هذا صحيح؟ نعم، أستطيع
العمل بكلتا الطريقتين، ولكن نعم، أحاول أن أبحث أولاً بنفسي. وأعتقد أن هذا
سيسلط الضوء على حقيقة أنك قادر على اتخاذ قرارات جيدة، وأنهم لن يضطروا
إلى الإشراف الدقيق على كل صغيرة وكبيرة فيما تفعله، وأنهم يثقون بأنك تستطيع إيجاد الإجابة الصحيحة،
وأنك لن تكون عبئاً عليهم، وأنك تمتلك المهارات اللازمة. أعتقد أن هذه طريقة جيدة
لترك انطباع أول جيد.
نعم، نعم. إذاً لدينا بعض العبارات المختلفة التي يمكننا استخدامها للإجابة على هذا السؤال.
على سبيل المثال، إذا أردت أن أتحدث عن نفسي لشخص ما، سأقول اسمي ديفيد براون.
أنا شغوف بتدريس اللغة الإنجليزية كلغة ثانية.
لقد أجريت حوالي 24,000 حصة دراسية عبر الإنترنت مع طلاب من جميع أنحاء العالم.
لقد درّست طلاباً أصغر سناً في المرحلتين الإعدادية والثانوية،
وأجد نفسي حقاً في العمل الذي أقوم به. في وقت فراغي، أفكر فيه أيضاً.
أحب قضاء الوقت مع عائلتي وأصدقائي وأحلم بالتكنولوجيا
الجديدة. لا أعرف. هذا ما قد أقوله إذا كانت لدي مقابلة عمل قريباً.
نورما (Nūrmā)، أخبريني، هل تعتقدين أن ذلك سيترك انطباعاً أول جيداً؟
نعم. أوه، أتمنى ذلك. لا أعرف ما إذا كان هذا الدرس أفضل لي أم لك
في الواقع. شكراً لك. شكراً. نورما، هذا الدرس مجاني. حسناً، إذاً ما الذي جعل
ذلك المثال سهل الفهم؟ أعتقد أنني تحدثت بسرعة قليلاً، ولكن ما
رأيك؟ ما الذي جعل ذلك المثال سهل الفهم؟ لا، في الواقع، ما
سمعته كان عن الخبرة التي لديك.
وأيضاً يمكنني أن أرى مدى الفئات العمرية التي يمكنك العمل معها. لذا
أعرف أنك تستطيع العمل مع الأكبر سناً أو الأصغر سناً. وأيضاً أنك شخص
يهتم بعائلته. حسناً، أيضاً، نعم، لديك بالفعل مهارات استماع جيدة.
أنا، بدلاً من قول "ما أستمع إليه*"، يمكنك القول "ما، ما سمعته" بالأحرى،
يمكنك القول "ما سمعته كان عن الخبرة التي لديك
وأيضاً أرى الفئات العمرية التي يمكنك العمل معها. لذا أعرف أنك تستطيع العمل مع
الأشخاص الأصغر سناً أو الأكبر سناً." لقد فهمتك تماماً. حسناً، إذاً لدينا أيضاً
هذا السؤال الآخر المهم جداً. يُطرح دائماً عندما تُسأل "ما هي نقاط قوتك؟"
لدينا فرصة للتألق. يمكننا أن نظهر للآخرين ما لدينا.
ما هي نقاط قوتك يا نورما؟ إذاً يمكنك، ولكن ماذا، ولكن يجب أن يكون الأمر محدداً بشأن هذا، أليس كذلك؟
لأننا يمكننا، يمكننا أن نقول لشخص ما إننا مستمعون جيدون،
ولكن متى كنت مستمعاً جيداً؟ وفي أي موقف يمكنك أن تكون أكثر تحديداً؟
هذا يمكن أن يساعد حقاً. إذا كان بإمكانك تقديم أمثلة محددة، محددة.
ثم عندما تُسأل، "ما هي أكبر نقطة ضعف لديك؟" يمكنك
اختيار نقطة ضعف حقيقية بسيطة تعمل على تحسينها بفعالية. هذا يظهر أنك
صادق. ويقولون إنه يجب عليك تجنب العبارات المبتذلة مثل، "أنا شخص يسعى للكمال"،
ما لم تتمكن من دعم ذلك بالأدلة بشكل عام. هل أنت حقاً شخص يسعى للكمال؟